okay so my favorite thing on youtube at
the moment is spider-man 3 trailer
release date videos that don't say when
the trailer release date is
and just say that the trailer is coming
soon yeah no [ __ ] sherlock
tom holland is gonna be there too big
big scoop there anyway i'm back
my back with a whole host of spiderman
2021 updates
that will be going over all the new
information that we have on the movie
we've got a lot to talk about in this
video and analyzing trailer release
dates for films in the last 20 years or
so
i think i've come up with a good
estimation on when we will actually be
getting a first look
we're also going to be discussing kevin
feige's comments on the casting rumors
for the movie
as well as toby maguire's deal being
finalized
this is your first time here then
welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man
now let's get into the breakdown okay so
over the weekend screeners for the first
three episodes of one division went out
to press members lucky enough to get
them
and most of these were put out so that
sites could prepare to interview
elizabeth olsen and kevin feige
lots of questions were of course fired
at them about the show
but many were picking fergie's brain on
the upcoming spider-man movie
especially because he's been pretty
tight-lipped throughout the pandemic
now if you've been following the film
then you'll have seen there's been a lot
of reports about characters such as
elektra returning
dr octopus andrew garfield kirsten dunst
and a lot more
is andrew garfield the character anyway
most of these have been confirmed
but there are still a lot up in the air
such as sandman the green goblin and
more
when discussing this he gave a very
ceo-like answer
but did let us know that at the very
least some will be going ahead
in an interview with comicbook.com
fergie said
i read some things i'm not sure i read
all things
terrible impression the fun thing about
online speculation when it comes to our
stuff
is how sometimes it couldn't be more off
the mark
and sometimes it's shockingly close and
that's held true for the last few years
but saying which is which would take
all the fun out of everything i also
like to say that heavy smiley show
is the best show well thanks thanks king
kev now that does give a lot of way to
the idea that going ahead
things across the mcu are about to
change massively
and when discussing what could be coming
down the line the marvel monarch said
the following
the biggest clue is the title of the
second doctor strange movie
that's the biggest clue of where the
multiverse of madness is taking us
and how we're exploring that it's
surreal to me that we're talking about
spider-man 3.
i worked on a movie called spider-man 3
many years ago
directed by sam raimi if i if i recall
correctly
so this clearly the shorthand of calling
it spider-man 3 now
it's fine we call it homecoming 3.
guys pretty much admitting that they're
just scraping the barrel at this point
but
but as for now the official title hasn't
been released
but i don't think it'll be too long
before we get confirmation of what it is
i've heard from several sources that the
film will be called homeworld
but you never know what's true and what
isn't especially in the super duper
pooper scooper business i think it does
definitely confirm though that the
multiverse will play a big part
and this of course allows for several
characters to come across
now that kind of leads us into our next
story and if you're enjoying the video
then make sure you show
that you have some spider sense and
subscribe to the channel for breakdowns
like this each and every day
anyway it's very clear that many
characters are going to be coming across
to the movie
and it has been long rumored that toby
maguire is indeed stepping back into the
spectacular spider-man shoes for the
film
you may remember that before christmas
it was said that we would actually be
getting our first look at the film in a
teaser before the end of the year that
would show
tom holland andrew garfield and toby
maguire together
there was even a video confirming this
posted on the latin sony channel
and this was quickly removed but it did
become clear that sony were putting
things in place
however apparently bully maguire was
living up to his reputation
and it was reported that the actor was
asking for a lot more money than the
studio were willing to give
i remember when i used to get bullied
into handing money over
and it seemed like mcguire knew he was a
key player and things going forward
so as being very very difficult to deal
with however
daniel rpk has said that the deal has
now been finalized
so yeah stop having your heart attack
we can rest now now he's a good loud
identity and and he scoops stuff well in
advance
which i think makes this a pretty
reliable statement it's also been posted
by the designer vagina women website
which is where i first saw it being
reported by another outlet
i was just i was just browsing for
lingerie for my wife yeah but i promise
it's not me and it just made me so
excited to see this finally go ahead as
i think it's the thing that everyone
wants to see
i think this will definitely be part of
the plan for marvel and if he'd asked
for any amount of lunch money they
likely would have just handed it over
mcguire is a huge get for the studio and
when i recently did a spoiler stream
with josh over at den of nerds
we discussed how fergie actually wanted
to sign raymie for doctor strange 2 over
scott derrickson
because he knew the amount of doors that
it would open for him and that it would
make getting actors like maguire or
molina that much easier
that's clearly the case and though the
screen time for toby isn't meant to be
massive
i actually think that he will appear in
doctor strange 2 in a far more fleshed
out role
sony clearly want to go ahead with more
characters as part of the spider-verse
and getting maguire and garfield back
opens up the avenues so that they can do
alternate franchises featuring different
versions of the webhead
i can actually see the three featuring
in this movie going off to do their own
separate things
and then being brought together again
down the line for a sort of
end game level event that has them
teaming up once more
now because the deal is signed we can
start looking towards when we will see
them united for the first time in a
teaser
and as i said earlier i've crunched the
numbers to give us a rough idea of when
things will be popping up online
now between the years of 2000 all the
way up to the year 2016
trailers typically tended to air roughly
six months before the release of a film
this average has of course been
massively skewed with all the delays
recently
so i thought i'd focus on those years
when there was more of a steady lineup
of the trailer to release date so we can
expect to see the first full trailer for
the film
roughly around june july however with
this being a big announcement in which
they want to show the three off together
i think that we will probably get
something before that now we already
know that the latin video is ready to
drop
i think that this in translated versions
of it will pop up relatively soon
once the studio is ready to make the
deal official now on top of this i
actually think that we'll get a proper
full look at the three together
come the end of february or maybe the
start of march
crunching the numbers again on first
look teasers
these tend to drop around the year to
seven month mark that our property is
due to come out
we're already past the air mark so it's
definitely not that
but the seven month one does line up
with the end of one division which is
due to have nine episodes and run for
eight weeks
if you watch the disney invest today
then you'll know that kevin feige said
that the show would set
the events of spider-man 3 and doctor
strange 2 so it makes sense to have a
tease at the end of it which showcases
things going forward
marvel is of course famous for their
post-credits scenes
and it seems unlikely that we'll be
getting a one division season too
so it makes sense to me that the series
will end with a tease towards the movie
that ties directly into it
aka spider-man 3 now we saw how this
worked with the mandalorian which set up
the boba fett spin-off
so if i had to put money on it i would
think that this series will end with
some sort of time to peter parker
and perhaps even show toby and andrew
doing things in their own respective
universes
now obviously i will be covering one
division week by week
so we'll find out sooner rather than
later if i'm right but in the meantime
i'd love to hear your thoughts on
everything that we talked about today
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
straw in which we're giving away three
copies
of the hobbit and lord of the rings 4k
box sets to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the news
the links to our socials are in the
description and you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button
below and as a thank you you get videos
like this early
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the fan theories and predictions for one
division which will be linked on screen
right now
we go over the returning characters who
we think the villain will be
and how vision is still alive so
definitely check it out after this
without the way thank you for sitting
through this i've been paul and i see
you next time
take care peace